historic flooding in Louisiana has
claimed at least seven lives more than
11,000 people are staying in shelters
this morning and more than 20,000 have
been rescued from rising water but
people have pulled together throughout
the devastated region to give each other
support Jamie wax is in Baton Rouge
where people are helping their neighbors
survive Jamie good morning good morning
for the past several days one of the
only ways to get around in certain parts
of Baton Rouge has been with a boat or
with something like this a Chevy truck
converted into a high-riding hunting
vehicle for this week this truck hasn't
been used for hunting it's been used for
rescuing people that have been stranded
by the floods when the water started to
rise Roberts Engelmann antique
Bonneville rolled into action how many
people have you rescued at this place
250 babies kids elderly 30 dogs this
video was taken as they plucked stranded
neighbors from their homes they're part
of a loose collection of volunteers
known locally as the Cajun Navy you
don't get emotional right when you do it
you just do it with 911 operators
overwhelmed Scott and Jessica gasps Bart
turned to Facebook for help
eventually boats arrived to take them
and their 11 children to safety what we
truly saw were friends neighbors
complete strangers rescuing people left
and right the officials had no idea this
is gonna happen so it's truly the guy
next door you should have seen the line
of people Patrick Mulkern heads up TV
and film complex Celtic studios its
massive sound stages usually the site
for movies like oblivion and The
Twilight Saga have been converted into
shelters for those left homeless there's
about 4,000 people here yesterday so it
was a small town no doubt about it as
devastating as the floodwaters have been
Mulhern says the outpouring of support
is a hopeful sign especially after a
tense summer of police shootings and
racial tension floodwaters don't
discriminate that you know they don't
care about race color creed religion
gender
you name it litrenta Sanford and her
children have been living at the shelter
since losing their homes several days
ago did you ever think you'd see
anything like this in Baton Rouge I
never thought that I will be dancing
with the Katrina victims haven't spared
Lisa well Meyer survived Hurricane
Katrina she moved to Baton Rouge after
losing her home in that storm nearly 11
years ago and finds herself flooded out
again what I've learned is it's not
about the material things it's about the
soul of Louisiana and that's what
they've got they've got a real big
healthy heart
Lisa well Meyer explained to us how the
city of Baton Rouge welcomed her family
and others from New Orleans after
Katrina she said now it's time for her
to repay the favor by helping those who
came to her rescue nearly 11 years ago
Gale talked about paying it forward
thank you very much Jamie